I jump I jump harder and higher than I  knew I was capable of to get away why  they're after me my parents Society The  Seekers rain slaps my open floors  wetting my face like a big wet towel  made of water there's no time I jump  across the creek and Scurry down a  slippery Hill jumping tears Gallop down  my cheeks mixing with the ice cold rain  warmth fills my chest when I remember  Veronica  dead it should have been me but they got  to her first and she was the only link I  had to the one orb the reality breaking  device summoned by the devil and created  by the Wizard's Apprentice in the 4th  Century BC before being buried in a  forest in Colorado before my stupid self  dug it up the universe was going to end  me but it started before that way way  before it started on a Tuesday in Mrs  Jackson's fourth hour geometry class